i still hate intros that time i got
reincarnated as a slime part 2 yep
episode 13. rimaru leads a party to get
to the marshlands and help the lizard
men so i had gone ahead and seized one
of the chick lizard men or lizard chick
or whatever fighting with one of the
high-ranking orcs she's getting her ass
handed to her so he steps in to help
when they get there rimuru helps the
wounded lizard chick and she explains
the uprising that gabaru had caused
he decides to send zoe again to get to
the chieftain and set him free back on
over to the dumbass gabiru who had
gotten his forces surrounded by the orcs
he also had realized that when the orcs
eat the lizard men they actually gained
their powers
but that aside an orc general appears
and gabriel thinks that it's the orc
lord so he challenges him to a duel
before that can happen we hop on over to
lord gelmut and laplace
were approached by trainee they have a
little skirmish that's kind of pointless
and she forces them to retreat back to
the dual words and no one's surprised
gaburu is getting [ __ ] destroyed
anime cliche kicks in and luckily gopta
is there to save him right before he's
killed
everybody else arrives marking the first
time that all of the side characters can
show off their true powers
long story short they're all open
phil mutes being a little [ __ ] because
everything's fallen apart and we learn
that he's working for a demon lord named
clayman
in the last scene raimiro spots the orc
lord and prepares to face it
episode 14. things aren't looking so hot
for the orcs which cues the entrance of
lord galmud hey
monologues about how they're planning to
make the orc lord into the next demon
lord
anyways galemute is pissed at everybody
and tries to attack gobbyroo the
lizard bro is loyal to him jump in front
of the shop being severely injured gilmu
charges up to finish the job which is
when rimaru decides he should probably
step in
and saves gobbyroo's life ramuru blocks
his piddly ass attack and proceeds to
smack him around a bit not knowing what
to do he begs the orc lord to step
in and help him but apparently he's not
a huge fan of gail mute anymore the big
boy uses his cleaver to decapitate
gelmute and proceeds to eat him
after consuming him the orc lord's
magickill spike allowing him to evolve
into the demon lord known as the orc
disaster
the cajun members volunteer themselves
to fight and even though hakuro had
landed a fatal blow
the demon lord's regeneration kicks in
keeping him alive
rimuru lets the great sage take over in
autopilot mode to fight the demon lord
but it turns into a stalemate when
rimiro's flames aren't enough to kill it
this forces reroute to take off the
autopilot and switches into his slime
form this turns into a battle between
the demon lord's starved ability and
reamer's predator ability while
consuming him rimaru sees that the orcs
were living in famine so the demon lord
went out to find food for them which is
when he ran into gel mute the demon lord
is put to rest and with him gone the
effects of the starved ability were
removed from the orcs putting an end to
the conflict
technically the kijin alliance should
come to an end now that the orcs have
been dealt with but they request to keep
working with rimaru anyways
episode 15. there is a meeting between
all of the races to decide what happens
now
in summary rimaru absolves the 150
000 remaining orcs of their crimes and
everybody agrees to work together in the
forest trainee titles rimaru as the
chancellor of the juror forced alliance
putting him in charge
the orcs also need a new leader so
rimaru names one of the pig boys geld
which is the same name that the demon
lord had possessed and was given by
gelmut he went on to name all 150
000 orcs and of course the lizardman
chief received the name
abiru his son gaby root was charged with
treason for the uprising and banished
from the clan
the lizard bros loyal to him decide to
go with him in their search for a new
home
gazelle duargo comes to meet with rimro
after hearing about how he had evolved
all of the orcs and about their new
thriving society
gazelle wants to determine rimaru's
worth through a duel with sorts
rimaru is able to defend all of his
attacks making him the winner and
earning gazelle's respect minor plot
twist hakuro was actually gazelle's
master growing up which is why rimaru
knew how to block his attacks
later while eating gazelles suggests
that they form a treaty together which
would acknowledge rimaru and his
followers as a new nation
the misha becomes known as the jura
tempest federation
and the town they're in is named rimaru
and made the capital
episode 16. gazelle also gives rimaru
vesta since his talents are going to
waste
and kaijeen is told to look after him to
know when surprise gabiru and the boys
joined their ranks also
and his sister had tagged along being
given the name sulka
after giving their names the lizardmen
evolve into dragon newts which are
surprisingly similar to humans and so
wait is tasked with training them for
some reason gabiru had kept the same
name but it was acknowledged by rimroo
which causes him to evolve also but
instead of looking like a human he just
turns purple vista is tasked with
researching new healing potions in order
to mass produce the ones that rimaru
makes
now we hop on over to the demons where
we meet the new white food candidate of
the show malim
nava also attending the meeting are the
demon lords carrion
and frey they discussed the fact that
since valdora is gone the non-aggression
pact should be discontinued
this is what moline was hoping for so
she goes to meet with rimaru
when she arrives she talks with rimuru
and says that she's just there to say hi
the kioshin fears she might be a threat
so they attack her but she's way more
powerful than all of them
rumors steps in to put an end to the
conflict and learns from the great sage
that her magickills are 10 times higher
than his
he negates the chasm of difference in
their skill by feeding her some honey
she loves it so much that she agrees to
call it a draw and never attack them
again in exchange for some more jump
ahead just a bit and she decides that
her and rimaru are now best friends and
she wants to live in their village
that seems nice on the surface but the
others speculate that befriending her
might upset the balance between the
demon lords
episode 17. we learned that vesta was
finally able to replicate the healing
potions that rimaru makes and seems to
have buried the hatchet with kaijin
reimu decides that they can produce
lower potency potions in order to sell
them
meanwhile phobia who is a beast keeper
working for the demon lorikarian
shows up and picks a fight with rieger
milan wasn't having any of that [ __ ] so
she knocks him out with one punch
[Music]
they talked with him once he had
recovered and he explains that he was
sent there to force
everybody in the town to serve carrion
rumor who doesn't want any conflict so
he lets him go and says that carrion can
meet with him formally if he wants to
talk
mullein tells them about their plans to
make a puppet demon lord and now that
that's fallen through apparently they're
the new target we then see that the
kingdom of falmouth had deployed a
scouting party led by a man named yom to
investigate the rumored orc lord while
heading through the force they come
across fuse and the three adventurers
who are on their way to meet with
rimarou who are being chased by a huge
monster when gopta comes across both
parties
gopta being the hidden gem of the show
saves everybody's lives by one tapping
the monster and securing food for the
entire village
reimaru is hoping to form trade with
both blumen and falmuth which they're
open to since king gazelle had
recognized them as a nation he convinces
both of them to spread the rumor that
yom and his men were actually the ones
that defeated the orc lord while the
tempest nation
lent them supplies and aid this
fabricated story will make them appear
as a less threatening group
and raise relations with the kingdoms
yoom and his companions are won over by
reroute so they swear their allegiance
to him
also increasing their numbers even more
we then meet a new face in tear who
meets with lord clayman they discuss
reimu and she also tells him that fury
seems to be getting ready for a fight
saying that kryptos was going to be
revived he then tasks her with going and
finding the location of the seal to see
if it's possible to tame kryptus
episode 18. phobia is wanting to get
revenge on malim for humiliating him but
isn't sure how to go about doing it
they're then approached by another mask
bro
named footman he is accompanied by tyr
and they offer to help him with their
problem
they say that the only way to defeat
malim is to become a demon lord himself
if he can combine his power with
corruptus then that would put him on the
same level as a demon lord so he agrees
to go with them
and get control of kryptos meanwhile
rimaru makes plans with fuse to make a
road connecting the tempest nation with
bluemint in order to form trade with
them
and back to phobia who was sent into a
cave by footman and tear to set cryptis
free
and let it inhabit his body we then meet
trya who is another dryad
and trainee's little sister she informs
them that corruptus had been released
and it's heading for their town we
also learned that corruptus is in a
sense valdora's child because it was
generated from a cloud of veldora's
magicals
it has also summoned 13 flying
megalodons to help it in the fight
william is eager to help out in the
fight but everybody refuses her saying
that they can't keep relying on her for
everything
episode 19. everybody's prepared to
fight corruptus with the help of
gazelles knights providing them with air
support fight secrets ensues and all of
the side characters work together to
kill the megalodons leaving just
corruptus as the last remaining threat
even after rimaru joins the fight and
everybody uses their strongest attacks
they only deal 30 percent damage to
kryptus
rimeru uses his appraisal skill to learn
more about it and he finds that it
possesses
an intense hate for moline he decides
it's kind of her business at that point
so he allows her to join the fight she
holds back her power just enough to one
shot corruptus while also managing to
keep phobia alive in the process
aura is removed from phobia and absorbed
by rimaru when he regains consciousness
he apologizes for the trouble and
explains that he was helped by footman
and tear
they label them along with laplace as
members of the moderate harlequin
alliance
ramiro of course decides to forgive
phobia for his actions and then they
meet with his master in carrion who is
eavesdropping nearby
carrion reprimands phobia by smashing
his face into the ground
and agrees to enter a non-aggression
pact with the tempest nation as an
apology
episode 20. things have calmed down a
bit after the fight and malim decides to
go back to work as one of the demon
lords
later that night rumuru has a dream of
shizu pleading to save the children he
thinks that this could be one of her
regrets so he decides to go to the
kingdom of igracia where shizu used to
teach
him and ranga head to ingrassia to find
the school freedom academy which was
established by one of shizu's students
arriving at the free union headquarters
he goes to meet with the grand master
he is greeted by shizu's old student
yuki kagurazaka who at first isn't too
happy to see him wearing shizu's mask
they almost get into a fight but rimrou
convinces him that he is from japan like
yuki
and the two of them hit it off talking
about manga and anime
after explaining that shuzu's regret was
leaving behind her students yuki is able
to have rimaru take over
shizu's class to teach in her stead yuki
also explains that the five children are
summoned and when they are summoned as
children they are given power to fulfill
a certain role
it's possible that their tiny bodies
can't take the massive fluctuation of
energy and abilities which will cause
their bodies to be incinerated
any person summoned to the world under
10 years old has died within five years
of being there
whole nations are involved in these
summonings because it's easier to just
summon a hero instead of building armies
to fight monsters
rimrou vows to find a way to save them
and we meet the five kids
there is kenya misaki age 10 ryota
sekiguchi age
10 gail gibson age 11. ellis rondo age 9
and finally chloe auburn age 10. episode
21
the kids are a little unruly so rimaru
uses ranga to keep them in check and
then they have one-on-one duels
he's hoping that the fights will burn up
their excess magicals and save their
lives
all of them have unique powers and take
turns trying to defeat rimaru but
ultimately fail
afterwards he found that the magic kills
weren't affected by the fight so it was
a total waste of time it then shows the
kids shizu's mask and says that he vows
to save them in her memory so they all
start to trust and respect him a little
bit more
vesta had taught him to use a work
portal so he uses that to go meet with
trainee his next hunch is that if they
can get superior spirits to inhabit the
kids like ifrit did to shizu that might
allow them to control their energy
he has training where they can fight
superior spirits and she suggests the
dwelling of spirits which is ruled by
the queen of spirits
the only problem is that trainee isn't
sure how to get into the dwelling of
spirits because the entrance she once
used had vanished
jump ahead one month and while out
training with the kids a
skydragon shows up and terrorizes
ingrassia reimaru goes to defeat the
dragon and after his display of power he
is invited to dinner by a merchant named
meal meyer
the dinner is just to repay rimaru for
saving the merchant's life from the
skydragon once they get to talking
though rimaru suggests having the
merchant come back to his town since
they want to start selling things but
aren't sure where to start there also
just so happened to be a thick blonde at
the party who knew about the dwelling of
spirits and where it's at rimaru gives
her a fat tip for the information and
they find out the location
now he has a new destination the old
nature park in the northern part of a
frontier nation called the republic of
ograssia
episode 22. ramiroo takes the kids there
and they go through the entrance ending
up in a labyrinth they hear a voice that
tasks them with destroying a robot
before they can meet with the spirits
looks intimidating but rainbow is able
to one shot it with his fire
they are then greeted by the small fairy
and great demon lord romarese of the
labyrinth
after they get to talking we learned
that she had built her golem using
spirit engineering which is similar to
what vesta had [ __ ] up and blamed on
kaijin she actually got the gollum's
parts from vesta's failed project
but anyways rimrou makes the request
that she takes them to the queen of
spirits to save the kids
turns out romarese is actually the queen
of spirits but fell from grace and
became a demon lord we also learned that
leon was once a hero and he had fallen
from grace also
he did this with the goal of summoning
somebody specific from another world we
also recall that traney had said that
she had no connections with the current
queen of spirits
what she doesn't know is that the
current queen had been reincarnated
with the memories of her past lives
which is when she knew training
that aside romerese takes them to the
deepest part of the labyrinth which is
where the dwelling of spirits is
although the spirits might not answer
them rommery suggests seifening off some
of their energy and creating a new
spirit
episode 23. gail is the first one to go
and he calls upon the spirits
no greater spirits show up but a number
of lesser spirits do reroute uses his
gluttony skill to absorb and unify the
spirits making a new superior
one the spirit has the earth attribute
and he combines it with gail allowing
him to keep his magicals in check saving
him from his imminent death
they repeat the process with alice
making a new superior spirit with the
space attribute when it's kenya's turn a
pure light spirit shows up and offers to
take care of him until he's grown up so
he merges with that spirit rio gets
another artificial spirit with water and
wind attributes
and the last one is chloe but before
they can complete the process
a woman's spirit shows up and interrupts
them rommery starts to panic
saying that the spirit is dangerous and
without saying anything she merges with
chloe
even though this wasn't exactly part of
the plan she still seems to be okay
romares goes on to explain that the
spirit is from the future and by
choosing chloe it's laid the foundation
for its own rebirth they can't really do
anything now because it already merged
with her upside is that chloe is safe
from her imminent death also so they're
just going to back burner that for now
as payment for ron maurice's help rimaru
gives her a new golem to replace the one
that he had destroyed
it's just a shell though so he summons a
demon to possess it and give it life we
then get a fast cryptic shot of some guy
spying on rimaru
in the last couple of scenes we also see
that he had left shizu's mask with chloe
saying it felt like the natural thing to
do
episode 24. we now jump into the past to
follow one of shizu's stories
a dying woman summons a demon to get
revenge for her partner's death before
dying herself
shizu is summoned to the kingdom of
filtwood along with other adventurers to
deal with the demon's resurrection they
believe that the demon's objective is to
recover its body from when it was alive
which is kept beneath the castle
shizu points out that since the demon
was able to defeat the champions the two
silver wings
it might be an arc demon one of the
guards then kills one of the adventurers
revealing that there was a lesser demon
residing inside of him they go on to say
that any adventurer that isn't willing
to work with them
is likely possessed by a demon and will
also be killed the demon from before
that made the contract with the dying
woman makes his presence known posing as
one of the adventurers and going by the
nickname black
he goes on to explain that the guards
were the ones that summoned the lesser
demons
jesus steps in to confront him and he
admits that he plans on killing
everybody in the room in order to get to
the demon that he's been tasked with
killing
this prompts a fight between the two and
shizu releases a powerful attack that
reveals him to be a demon also when he
lands a blow on her mask
it deflects it and he comes to the
conclusion that her mask suppresses time
this is enough to deter his attack and
forces his retreat shizu recalls how
leon told her about the most powerful
demons called progenitors and instead of
names they're referred to by colors
anyway she is then summoned by one of
the knights to meet with the king
and he ends up taking her beneath the
castle turns out the king and minister
are working for the demon she was hired
to defeat
he has taken on the persona of orthos
which was the hero who had defeated him
before he was brought back to life
since he had acquired a name he became
an arc demon aka a greater demon general
and plans to kill shizu now that she
isn't at full strength
ultimately he wants to absorb her power
and take control of her mask so they get
into a fight shizu is too weak to fight
and thinks about letting efreet free to
fight in her stead but then black makes
his reappearance
he goes on to kill the king and minister
it's also revealed that he was hired by
the champions the two silver wings after
they were defeated by orthos
orthos has his soul destroyed by black
to prevent his reincarnation which also
purges all of the demons in the kingdom
afterwards the story is told that the
demon black had killed the king and
minister but was then defeated by shizu
black is very much alive though and was
also the one that was spying on rimaru
in the last couple of scenes there is
some foreshadowing saying that black
will be summoned by rimaru and receive
the new name of diablo
i'm going to be doing the future seasons
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the that time i got
reincarnated as a slime recaps in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros is outros